foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships I'm
your host Dave Ramsey Jade warshaw
Ramsey personality newly minted well
here has been on a couple of times on
the air so far and gonna do gonna do
this hour with me is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five just a reminder
Jade has led a bazillion Financial Peace
University classes has listened to every
show that I've ever done in 30 years so
she knows all the answers to all the
questions and uh oh and uh she and Sam
paid off almost a half a million dollars
in debt okay that's a tall order Dave
but uh the 460k of debt that that one's
about right the part the first one was
correct the first one was correct I mean
no the last one was correct yeah okay
and the others might have been slightly
exaggerated slightly slightly definitely
listen to you for the better part of 15
years almost all three hours well you
and Sam used to play answer the question
in the car before I did yes we did
people would ask a question y'all see if
you could beat me to it oh yeah you're
talking about true nerds here yeah and
and I used to put the personalities to
the test when they came in I listened
very closely to those answers but of
course they were nailing it too so ah of
course and now you just lied again
because they don't always know well well
you know that's not for me to say Dave
that's for you to say
all right let's start off with Chicago
David is on the line hi David welcome to
the Ramsay show
you too sir thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so I have a side hustle that has turned
into something far more lucrative than I
thought it could ever be to be honest
with you that's cool and it's making
yeah it's making real money
help me what's real money
um I made 30 000 last year with it
thirty thousand as a side hustle that's
good okay
totally unexpected side hustle
um but I cannot tell you where a single
one of those thirty thousand dollars
went
um I looked at the reporting over the
weekend and I almost threw up
my question is like how do I came this
side hustle because it's very hand to
mouth my own personal thing no one
watches it I work and I get paid I just
want to be better with it and actually
have some money to to look at at the end
of the year what are you doing dude
so you might be able to hear in the
background but I'm actually a bird
sitter it sounded like animals yeah uh
she she is not calming down and I she
will knock it off of me but here we are
um but no I I bird said for about a
hundred different parrots in Chicago
um the number one guy on Google if you
search bird sitting Chicago I'm the
first guy that pops up so 2023 could be
a big year for me and I again just want
to make sure I'm not burning the cash as
it comes in is it just you you're the
only one bird sitting it is it is just
me yeah so I have a certification I've
worked with parrots for over half my
life and I'm very very good with them
um but yes it's just me and my me and my
Ultima driving around taking care of the
birds wow very cool good for you man
that's fun thank you so the easiest way
to get started on this is just treat it
like a business because it is
and I would just open up a separate
checking account bird sitters are us or
whatever it is right and just uh put
your name on there uh David so and so
DBA doing business as uh bird Setters
are us and you just do it in your social
security number you don't even need a
tax ID number to do it and then throw
all of your bird sitting money into that
account
and and then you can just pull up the
register on that account at any point
and you can tell what's going on you can
tell where the money is right and then
if you pull it out of there to bring it
home quote unquote out of the business
you need to set aside a fourth of it for
taxes because as you have discovered you
have seven thousand five hundred dollars
in taxes due on this don't you sure do
yep and don't have any money
well that I was
I must move I'm the processor that I use
will save the taxes for you so I have
that set aside at least so I'm not like
facing down Uncle Sam with a brown face
good good um I do have another kind of
follow-up question how do you find the
discipline because I I did that I made a
threat checking account and I'm like oh
I'm not going to look at the money and
then I'm like oh this thing this thing
this thing it just it just goes my mom
says I'm like a sieve with cash limit it
goes out of the it goes out of the bird
account
yeah I just spend it like what are some
tips for discipline on that like okay
you don't have a budget on your personal
account do you
have a budget on anything yeah I know I
could tell it sounds like he needs to
sit down and and keep his money separate
you've got your personal money on one
side you've got your business money on a
separate side and uh David it sounds
like with your business you really need
to get organized and write down what
your outgo is what your expenses are
right and and and how much money that
you're bringing in to find out if you
really can't you know and and decide can
I take a payroll if I can it's going to
be this amount and I'm going to do it
you know every month and really just get
organized it sounds like that's really
what you're lacking because the business
sounds like it's making money it almost
sounds like it's making so much money
for you that you feel like you can be
frivolous and I think that that's a
dangerous place to be lazy um what's the
uh what's your day job pay
so no I make 70k a year okay so you have
a hundred thousand dollars coming in how
old are you
33 and you're broke
yes okay here's your why
you need to get disgusted with how
stupid that is
yes it is so stupid I know I mean that's
a good thing I mean it's like after
covet I ate so many donuts that I got
disgusted about how fat I got
so because I ate every donut in a 50
mile so you have to get disgusted and go
I'm gonna change this crap this is crazy
and I you know you got to have a there's
a healthy level of disgust that precedes
human transformation
like I've had it I'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired I don't like this
feeling of being this inept I don't like
this taste of regret with a hundred
grand going through my fingers and I
have no idea where it goes that taste on
my tongue is awful it's like a bad
fruitcake this time of year right and so
I want to stop that so now now we've got
you and you called here and so you
already knew right you are you knew that
you told me what I just told you back I
didn't tell you anything new I'm not you
called him stupid no I just said what
are you doing stupid okay so no you know
but here's the thing now you gotta now
you got a why because if you keep eating
like you've been eating You're Gonna
Keep looking like you've been looking
you keep spinning like you've been
spinning you're gonna keep being broke
like you've been broke you got to change
your habits so we're gonna sit down and
do a personal budget on where the
money's gonna go and then when we move
money out of the bird account into the
personal account minus tax withholding
then and we've got an assignment for it
already preset in the personal budget
but the personal budget is just regret
avoidance it's just Financial hangover
avoidance
it's like a drink too much and I feel
like crap for three days right it's the
same thing you got this tape you got
this hangover and it's the exact same
thing you've been partying and and
you're tired of it it's time you just
said I'm gonna grow up good for you well
done we're going to help you hang on
send you a copy of the book The Total
Money Makeover which will walk you
through exactly what to do but you just
need to say I'm worth fixing this
because I don't like where I am so I'm
going to change it this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ly minted Ramsey personality Jade
warshaw is my co-host today
she starts her career off with a bird
sitter
here on the Ramsey show this is how we
break them in here we do it right
I'm glad to know it was birds at first I
thought it was monkeys so oh
I don't can't count on one hand the
number of bird questions I've gotten
over 30 years but we just added them we
start you off with that so there you go
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself whyblinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more always use the magic word to get
the deals it's Ramsay that's the promo
code Ramsay all right today's question
comes from Linda in Colorado she says
this my husband changed positions within
his company and needs to return his
company work truck and we now need to
buy a quote new truck a lot of new
trucks and used trucks are within a few
thousand dollars of each other uh
sometimes you used ones are almost the
same as new I have heard you say many
times not to buy new because of the
immediate depreciation of driving it off
but does this weird Market skew that
advice
my husband also reminded me that you
said that if you have enough money you
should just buy what you want even
though we are debt free and have a 5
million dollar assets and cash I am
still kind of a penny pincher and want
to keep the truck at or under 30k what
advice can you give us regarding new or
used oh man I love this question you
know
I get it like I think sometimes you can
look at the car market and you can think
okay like I want to do everything the
Dave way and especially with them it
sounds like they're well into baby step
seven you know I think sometimes when
you're in that you just get used to that
that feeling of holding back and you
know putting aside but you know I think
that you guys have earned the right
Linda to go ahead and buy this truck
you've got five million in net worth and
and we teach here that if you're if your
net worth is over a million dollars you
have earned the right to purchase the
car that you would like to drive and not
only a used vehicle you could actually
purchase it outright now if that doesn't
feel right for you I think that's fine
but basically right now I'm just giving
you permission to go ahead and get the
car that or the truck in this case that
you're wanting to get now you know you
gave him permission to get the truck she
didn't want to no that's true she
doesn't want to and they wanted it might
not she wanted us to tell him we can't
buy a truck when he's got five million
dollars dude buy whatever truck you want
buy the truck and seriously that's
ridiculous and she wants to keep it
under 30k I think no no no no no you
need to get a good truck yeah let them
go here big truck big expensive five
million dollars I mean seriously now
that's you you drive like no one else so
later you can drive like no one else yep
and so that's the thing and and you're
in great shape has nothing to do with
the new market versus the used Market I
don't need to give you a rationalization
the only rationalization for you buying
a brand new freaking truck with five
million dollars is you want it or in
this case he wants it so buy the man a
truck that's what you do that's why you
do this it's a small thing yeah it's
just it if you listen let's say he
drives a sixty thousand dollar truck all
right let's double her thing
forgets to put insurance on it doesn't
set the parking brake it rolls off the
cliff right
so now instead of five million dollars
they have four million it's a fraction
940
000 they're still rich
do it again tomorrow
well I don't know it still doesn't
matter the point is it doesn't matter
that's right that's when you know you
can afford it yep it doesn't matter
mathematically you know when you don't
do it is when you make fifty thousand
dollars a year and you buy a sixty
thousand dollar truck and you've still
got a student loan debt and three credit
cards and your sixty thousand dollar
truck turns into thirty thousand in
value in 13 seconds and then you scratch
your head and wonder why you can't fund
your kids college fund because you're
broke see that's stupid straight up yeah
because the new market and the East
Market are close oh shut up you're bro
you don't need to buy a truck that's
what it you know so don't the
rationalization doesn't matter it's the
reasoning and the reasoning's got to do
with the ratios so you're exactly right
Jade lady you're sweet and you're kind
and you're Penny pitching ways is what
got you all here but you need to enjoy
the money too I'll tell you one other
thing you need to do you need to turn up
your generosity button about three
notches that's it crank it up a little
more and that helps you with your penny
pinching that's okay you're when you're
giving more it also allows you to enjoy
the money more in personal purchases as
without feeling like you've done
something wrong absolutely because then
again you're playing that ratio game
exactly exactly Tim Is With Us in Kansas
City hi Tim welcome to the Ramsay show
oh hi you didn't want to talk about
being better than I deserve I get to
talk to you guys today I love it man
bless your heart Merry Christmas to you
how can we help Merry Christmas to you
so I I have a question I want to know if
a decision that I want to make would be
considered in your guys's eyes Financial
infidelity and so my wife and I I I've
been listening to you for a long time uh
you know my wife is not on 100 on board
we've we've come to like an agreement
between the Dave Ramsey Way and the not
Dave Ramsey way and that basically is
we've we've paid off all of our debt
right we have no debt except an RV and
we've had this RV for a couple years and
her the the the agreement we came to was
she said I don't care if everything
falls apart and they come take this
thing away it doesn't matter it's a
luxury and you know I say okay so I
could agree to that but
still beat down I'm like man I just want
to pay it off you know and and you know
we we have enough money and you know
enough margin uh that I I could you know
how much is the RV worth pay it off
uh probably about 20 000. what do you
owe on it
that's uh 17. you got the money in the
bank to pay it off
um
not not outside of our uh emergency fund
no okay I mean I I mean all of my money
is so where's the infidelity where is it
you're going to be lying to your wife
that's my question well we we the the
LIE would be we agreed like I agreed
that yes okay we we would work towards
paying off all of our debt but she she
said no I don't want to spend extra time
and money paying off the RV because she
did like she said what does she want to
do what what does she want to do with
the money so if you've got the margin
laying around in your budget what does
she want to do with that money
we moved on to
um the following baby steps you moved
under your own plan you're not following
the baby steps oh I agree I agree don't
then don't say okay yeah so I mean we we
funded our emergency fund and started
contributing to retirement okay now what
this means is you ever how old are you
41. okay when I was a little kid which
was like a thousand years ago it's
probably older than you probably way
older you probably don't remember this
we played this dumb game called mother
may I and if you took a step forward
without permission you had to take two
steps backward do you remember that
I do okay that's where you are you took
steps forward without permission now
you've got to take two steps back
meaning you guys got to get back to
ground zero and start talking again
about the vision for our life about
where we want to be when we're 70 years
old do I want to have a freaking RV
payment when I'm 90 right let's back up
to that instead of you agreed to some
stupid butt stuff you shouldn't have
agreed to and you guys need to back up
and work on your marriage and
communication and value combination and
then the RV becomes a symptom not the
problem
okay that makes sense
yeah yeah so the the my bot my bottom
line is this you acquiesce and I'm not
suggesting you stir up trouble all the
time in your marriage but by acquiescing
you were under the illusion that you all
were now in agreement and you're still
not in agreement
it's lucky that you guys got that debt
paid off that that kind of happened by
by accident he did it yeah she she
agreed to that part of it he agreed to
that part of it so we accomplished the
one goal but you're not in agreement
about how money should be handled and
life should be lived that fooled them
into thinking that they were on the same
page but you guys are nowhere near it
yeah you're you're still not because
you're calling us saying I don't I don't
want to do this
exactly I made a bad deal with my wife
and I got to go back and undo the deal
because I didn't really believe what I
did and so that's why I'm taking two
steps back let's reset the vision for
our marriage and then the RV thing is a
naughty it's a non-issue because it's
honestly Pretty stinking silly but
you've got this debt on this RV it
really is it's not just picking on you
or her but I mean do you want to be 92
with an RV dead no well the RV that's
not the problem uh it's the symptom
exactly right this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Merry Christmas America welcome to the
Ramsay show Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money Jeff is with us Jefferson
Salt Lake City hi Jeff how are you
hey how you guys doing Jade welcome to
the show thanks a lot Jeff
good to be here with you I just uh
wanted this before my question just
wanted to quickly say thanks Dave so
much you know three years ago I was a
ninety thousand dollars in student debt
and as of today I am zero dollars in
student debt way to go hero well done
just wanted to say wouldn't have done it
without you man I tuned into you during
covid so my question is is there a
strategy to uh to maxing out your Roth
IRA
um should I do it January 1st and get it
done with and put it all in Max it out
for me and my wife the beginning of the
year or is there some strategy of taking
more time throughout the year to Max
that out
okay well the the industry teaches
um a wonderful process called dollar
cost averaging
that if you when you're steadily
investing a little bit every month like
in your 401k or uh if you set your IRA
up to be on a monthly draw then uh in
January the market is down you're buying
cheap shares later on you're buying more
expensive shares as the market goes up
and goes back down you're buying cheap
shares so you get this the average of
your dollars across dollar cost
averaging and you get to see this
wonderful mathematical thing happen that
shows your money growing and the other
benefit of that is is that it's not
emotional at all because you just plug
it in and never change it you always
invest now having said that what beats
dollar cost averaging
is a lump sum investment at the
beginning of the year
the downside of that is it's very
emotional because here's the rule here's
the thing to think about the market is
average 11.8 since it started okay
so let's say it averages
and did an average year it made 11
and you put in eight thousand dollars at
the beginning of the year in January so
you make eight percent on 11 now you
make eleven percent on eight thousand
dollars for 12 whole months right
right follow me if it runs average
and you Dole it out 1 12 a month through
the whole year you did not make eleven
percent on eight thousand dollars you
made eleven percent on about four
thousand dollars
right right you follow me so if the
market is doing average or up lump sum
is the thing the average comes from a
place it's the average of the up and the
down so you can kind of count on average
now however you could put in let's just
say out loud you can put it in and what
would it do by the end of the year it
could be it could be worth less
right right and so if it goes down
you know it makes it worse if you lump
sum it but if the market continues to
average what it is always averaged on
average you're always going to come out
better off lump suming
so I lump signs but that's because of
averages and I'm you know and so on
average most the time that's going to
work
more times than not that's great yeah
but in and you know even if you made
let's see uh uh six percent seven
percent on eight thousand dollars rather
than
11 on four thousand dollars it'd be the
same you still make more money right
even if the market didn't do what it
usually does not it's down but it's just
not up as much as it usually is so
that's why it works out so as long as
you can emotionally afford to open up
your uh computer screen and go oh crap
it went down and you don't freak out
right if you can do that and I can do
that because I never put it in I never
look at it again once I put it in there
I'm just thinking out 20 years I'm not
thinking out to two days and Jeff if you
max out your problem
if you max out your Roth is that your
full 15 percent
or what does that put you at
percentage-wise close close to it be
close to it yeah I think I have a little
bit more after that if I do it for me
and my wife okay okay because I was
thinking you might be able to get the
best of both worlds in some ways where
you're maxing out is this a Roth 401k or
an IRA
Ira okay but you can't lump show me 401K
oh that okay well there you go so he
could get the The Best of Both Worlds by
lump suming that and then still doing
some dollar cost averaging into his
normal formula into a 401k yeah that's
true certainly the balance over there
because you have a choice in the 401K
you've got a dollar cost average right
that's right yeah it does feel better
like I know you're saying it's emotional
I actually think it's even easier on me
it's January 1st I can just
do it all and say hey look I'm I'm like
almost my 15 for the year I can kind of
breathe and just get it done with it's
almost a little easier for me but if you
can set it and forget it and a lot of
people can but some people can't
so you know if you're not going to be on
Twitter going Dave Ramsey telling me to
do this and here it is September and I
lost this money oh shut up you didn't
understand what the flip I was talking
about okay yeah I gotcha if you know if
you're not that guy then we're okay but
you know the whole most horrible advice
I've ever heard in my life the guy who
has told more people how to be
millionaires than anybody else I
listened to him for 20 seconds and no as
long as you're not that idiot and you're
not you're not Jeff no he's not an idiot
he's going to be a baby steps
millionaire here in a minute I think
you're right because hey he's paying
attention B's asking questions like that
absolutely good questions Josh is with
us Josh is in Louisville Kentucky hi
Josh how are you
thanks for having me on sure what's up
so wanting to eliminate credit card debt
by the end of 2023
but on the main income of my
household and my wife had a hobby that
she has to decide but
that's not enough to really tackle the
eliminate the credit card debt so I'm
wondering is it time to give up the
Hobby and pursue a you know get her to
get a quote-unquote real job what's
y'all's income at this point
combined
combined we're looking at
uh
approximately 60
000 53 from me and then seven
from her
you said 63 from you and seven from her
so 70.
no uh 53 for me and then seven okay a
60k total and um you said it's credit
cards that's all the debt you have in
the world uh besides the mortgage is it
just the credit cards or is that just
what you feel like you're focusing on
right now credit card okay and how much
fourteen four thousand
and you guys are working the baby steps
in order have you guys
yeah we've tried you know the envelope
and budget you know all the spreadsheets
and we've tried you know the different
methods and you know it's easy to stick
for you know
a short period of time but then
you know
see and get off course and then yes you
earning more money is not going to make
you stay the course and I think it's
great to earn more money I'm never
opposed to that Dave but you sticking to
your budget and you guys deciding that
this is the plan we're working the plan
that's got nothing to do with you
earning money you sticking to your
budget doesn't have anything to do with
you earning more money or not that's you
just deciding that you and your wife
getting together deciding and saying
this is what we're doing and we're we're
pinky swearing on this and we we are
trusting each other that this is the
plan and we're keeping our word on that
yeah what do you do
I work in finance
how old are you
31 so you're working 40 hours
yes sir okay and what's her hobby that
you're you're calling a hobby she works
but she's done making money at it so
she's got a side hustle that's breaking
even she's an artist
and what type of artist
uh she paints and Designs uh jewelry so
she's an acrylic artist I see okay and
she puts y'all have children
yes we have one child he's five okay and
how much time does she put into acrylic
art to make seven thousand dollars a
year
holiday season is the busiest time and
so she's putting in
uh sometimes it's the rest of the year
though after the holiday season's over
she's not putting in three hours four
hours a week on it
oh no total during the down Seasons I
mean it's probably total per week you
know 12 to 20. yeah so no it's 12.
um it's not 20. not sure otherwise you'd
have a house full of this crap because
it wasn't selling or you're selling it
for a penny a piece so uh no so yeah I
think she keeps her Hobby and she picks
up a side hustle and you pick up a side
hustle and the two of you commit to
doing a budget
and then you pay off this debt in a year
why don't you work twice as hard as her
that'll be okay
this is a Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
guys the Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway
ends in three days count them one two
three that means you've got three more
chances to win but you've got to go to
ramsesolutions.com
giveaway and enter enter every day to
increase your chances to win our five
thousand dollar grand prize of course no
purchase necessary and you must be 18 to
win
ramseysolutions.com giveaway the ten
dollar sale is going on while you're
there check out the number one
best-selling books like Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires
all of Rachel Cruz's book all of John
deloney's books and so on ten dollars
hey
that's like stocking stuffers hardback
books what happened to inflation I guess
we our marketing team forgot about it uh
ramseysolutions.com check it out take
advantage of these deals and register
for the 5 000 giveaway Jade
it is important
and we saw a theme developing throughout
the hour we did
um
that we identify
we all me included have a tendency to
treat the symptom rather than the
problem absolutely absolute case yep and
uh the problem with the last caller's
household was not his wife's income
the problem was they're not on a budget
and they don't have a plan
and he wasn't working extra
and yet he wanted her to so there's all
kinds of other issues going on there
that had nothing to do with her he
probably just didn't like her acrylic
art thing well it's easier to focus on
that yeah that's the problem with the
truck is not new versus used the the
problem is just whether or not we can
afford it right so you got to go
hardcore and go okay what is the root
what is down below the soil
that's causing this discussion I'm not
in agreement with my wife about the RV
and so you know asking a question should
I lie to her and pay it off
no I will never tell you a lot of your
wife under any circumstances
um you know I can't uh no no you don't
you don't you just don't do I mean
that's not a what that means is if I'm
feeling that pressure it means there's
something else going on so always look
for folks and I have to look for this in
the mirror is okay what's the problem
the the symptom is I got fat from eating
too many donuts but what's the problem I
discovered that during high stress
scenarios when I work 16 hours a day
that I try to out eat my stress right
I'm a stress eater I discovered that so
I had to discover the real problem I
went oh okay I can't eat every donut in
sight just because I'm stressed out just
because I'm trying to figure out a way
to keep a company open in the middle of
covet right and so I can't do that it's
not it's it's counterproductive I'm
going to get fat and die of a heart
attack with Donuts stuck in my heart
arteries right and they'll open me up
and go he died of he needed a donut
ectomy and he didn't get one so I mean
what's the real problem and what's the
real symptom the donuts weren't the
problem they were the symptom absolutely
the fat was not the problem it was the
symptom well each of those required an
internal realization
they're trying to focus on the external
thing it's it's the car or it's the RV
it's the budget but each of those
required them looking at something
internally and going you know what the
issue is I'm afraid to talk to my wife
about sticking to the budget I'm I have
Penny pinched my whole entire life and I
have a scarcity mentality and now is my
chance I don't have to have that anymore
that's internal and even with this last
caller all of this requires you to look
Inward and find out what's at the core
route it's almost always internal Davids
it's rarely external with this stuff you
know it's one of the reasons that we've
been so successful over 30 years at
Ramsey helping people guiding them as
they transform their lives is because we
recognized unlike most people in the
financial business not everybody but
most of us I grew up in the financial
business academically trained and most
of us were taught if we fix the math
it'll be okay
and it's not a math problem it's a
person in the mirror problem personal
finances 80 Behavior it's only 20
percent head knowledge and so you can't
just fix the math until you fix the
cause of the math which usually has
something to do with the person in my
Mirror Michael Jackson said it I'm
starting with the man in the mirror oh
I'm asking him to change his ways
because I will just keep going I'm red
I'm you can probably just break out in
song and it would be the first time it's
ever happened on this show they'd get
the hook they'd hook me out of here no
no not you we've heard you're saying
you're seeing well so yeah but you're
exactly right that's that's the thing it
is the man in the mirror and uh the lady
in the mirror it's you know no one duct
taped me to the bed and force-fed me
donuts that's right it didn't happen
that was a choice of free will I could
check with Sharon but I don't think she
did she did I can promise you not the
skinny woman nope not her no she's um
she she was no she she was not she was
not for the donut plan I'm just saying
so uh quite the opposite of feeding them
to me but um here just eat another
sickness that early I want to get rid of
you die early I'm taking everything oh
yeah so I mean that no that was not her
so but no I mean that we can lie but
here's the thing if you're having a
situation like this my my teaching for
this segment the thing I'm bringing up
Jade and I are talking about is all of
us and I'm freely admitting my own
weaknesses in this area and going okay
how do I transform how do I do this well
I you know I have to engage in a
something that causes me to change the
problem and the symptom will fix itself
that's right that's right
self-realization
yeah there's something that happens and
my dad used to say it all the time he
would say you know go clean up the
garage and I would go you're going to
help and he go no I thought of it that's
half the answer
and so you you know I've done half the
work now because I thought of it so that
that realization is half of the work oh
yeah they say they say that all the time
half the hardest part of the problem
solving is realizing that you had a
problem to begin with and once you can
take full ownership over that and I mean
full ownership because a lot of times
you can say you have a problem but you
can start blaming others I know when Sam
and I were getting out of debt Dave and
I know I'm pivoting here when Sam and I
were getting out of debt we knew we had
a problem but we are still blaming other
people yeah we're blaming this
parakeet guys the first call was blaming
the spouse he sure was this whole hour
yeah they sure were I mean he didn't
blame the bird he didn't blame the birds
he blamed himself with nobody else but I
mean she blamed him for the pickup he
blamed her for the RV he blamed her for
not wanting to take the extra job it's
always somebody else I didn't catch that
pattern that's a good catch yeah there
as long as you look Dave I've heard this
my pastor used to say this all the time
you cannot blame your way to a better
life it's impossible how to preach as
long as you're blaming others you will
not do what it takes for you to succeed
because you're going to be waiting
around for someone else to do it for you
which sounds a lot like the culture
right now kind of like victim thinking
victim mentality it's this idea of
arrogance like someone else did this to
me well yeah and I'm sure it's Dunkin
Donuts and Krispy Kreme's fault the the
marketing they make those dead gum
Donuts delicious it's all their fault
and not they're not nutritious and they
didn't put the calories on the label big
enough oh no warning from the surgeon
donut General it has nothing to do with
you getting in your car and turning the
key and and spending your money and
putting them in your and in your gullet
oh my God
gullet gullet comes out on the first
hour with Jade that and the parakeet
well there we go all right this is this
is legendary Right Here legendary radio
hey seriously folks that's the whole
thing so um
yeah it's
it's a painful thing I was whining after
filing bankruptcy with one of my good
friends and you know they're a good
friend because I'll tell you the truth
and he goes you know you've been whining
for about a year blaming the IRS and
blaming the banks and blaming everybody
else at what point are you gonna look in
the mirror and go you signed up for this
trip
oh yeah I like you go jump in the creek
is that the same thing to Sam yeah he
wanted to blame the you know our student
loans we had 280 000 in student loans
and it's real easy to say well you know
we were 18. it was it was a student loan
company it was our parents they never
should have let us sign that loan and
you know what that could be true that
could be true but you may never get the
the apology Dave you may never get the
restitution you may never get that
person coming up to you and saying hey I
could have done for 200 000. yeah or
here's a check at some point you've got
to take responsibility for that and you
can make it you know you can have the
right reason all day why this was a bad
deal or why this shouldn't have happened
but after a while those reasons start
turning into excuses and it becomes up
to you to do something different ladies
and gentlemen you see why Jade warshaw
is now on the team oh baby that'll
preach good hour good job good stuff
well done Austin Ben James Zach Andrew
in the booth the booth dudes making the
show happen Jade warshaw's First full
hour you know it was led legendary well
done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show we're dead as dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
actually love and create real amazing
relationships this is the Ramsey Show
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose and host of the Ken
Coleman show where he talks about career
and jobs every day answering your
questions is also my co-host today you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money Tim starts off this hours in
Knoxville hey Tim what's up
hey good afternoon Dave I'm Jade thanks
for taking the call and a Merry
Christmas to you Merry Christmas to you
I have
I have an insurance question
um otherwise uh my wife and I who are
just approaching retirement age or doing
well following along the baby steps uh
but I do have a whole life insurance
policy sorry to say uh and I'm trying to
find out what's my best way of dealing
with that now what's my best exit
strategy from it
cancel it but let's talk about it
um also uh uh what's your net worth
uh just under a million okay
how old are you
uh 65 well done good work
and uh so what do you make a year
uh currently I am certainly very tired
but uh between my wife and I we're about
90 000. what do you make
um I make about 80. okay all right and
so she's got a part-time gig and you got
a A actually she's collecting Social
Security oh okay how old is she
67. okay all right
so the million dollar net worth is what
in mutual funds and your retirement
accounts or what
uh mutual funds and cash okay if it
makes eight percent a year that's eighty
thousand dollars
right
so if it's invested in good mutual funds
which the market is averaged 11.8 so
over time if it averages around eight
percent it makes about what you make
uh is your home paid for
absolutely good 100 debt free kids are
grown and gone or not any or what
uh kids are grown and gone and that's
why we feel the uh uh insurance policy
is no longer necessary yeah that's kind
of my point that's what I'm leading to
you're self-insured by the fact that
you're 100 debt free if you die she's
okay
your money makes as much as you make
if she wanted to draw down on that money
she could keep your exact same income
coming in uh same thing of something Pat
if she passed away same situation and so
your need for life insurance of any kind
is gone if you don't want to keep it so
in that case if that if you come to that
same conclusion that I did then you
would simply just cancel the whole life
policy and they will send you the cash
value now they will argue and whine and
tell you there's tax ramifications and
other lies uh and carry on like you've
done some kind of evil thing but you
haven't and or something stupid and you
haven't you just got rid of a bill
what's the cash value do you know
actually sixty seven thousand yeah okay
I gotta go buy you something nice man
cash it out that's what I would truth
and I think the advice that Dave gave is
really important when you say no and you
want to get away from these folks it's
like trying to get out of one of those
email lists that you signed up for
there's about 17 questions they try to
guilt you they try to spin you and you
should understand that's what you're
going to face and you got to go into
that phone conversation or if it's face
to face knowing absolutely clearly why
and that's why I love that you walked
him through the why you've got to
understand the math and then they can't
talk you out of it yeah and I don't you
know there's no point in debating
with a person who sells car leases
about car leases
they suck
there's no reason to debate it and the
guy that sells car leases I I've made
this mistake this is I mean a guy called
me more Christian Brothers we need to
discuss this and I'm like yeah you know
Christians can do math let's do it and
so
um so I'm like no it's a bad deal
in the name of Jesus it's a bad deal and
so you know I mean and uh but so what we
ended up was I finally figured out in
the conversation I had something I was
talking about that I believe and it's
his job all right yeah so he in order
for him to lose the argument
if he's going to keep his job he has to
be a hypocrite
or he has to believe he won the argument
or or Dave's just too dumb to understand
and he keeps doing what he keeps doing
so those convinced against their will
are of the same opinion still so there's
no sense in arguing with a whole life
life insurance agent because if you win
the argument they have to quit their job
that's a hard argument
you're just trying to cancel a policy
mm-hmm
so just say like no is a complete
sentence
yeah that's right no no just tell me
what we need what part of no didn't you
get
cancel the stupid thing no I'm not
leasing a stupid car you can go do it if
you want but no what about don't you
don't you want to argue no I don't want
to argue about this because there's a no
win in the argument because you have to
quit your job if I win the argument
because I will have convinced you that
what you're doing is screwing people
and unless you're just a doofus You're
you're going to have to quit your job
and so I'm not going to I'm not going to
enter into this with you I'll talk about
it as a concept you can listen to me on
YouTube and if you decide that then you
can quit your job but
but it's not a you see what I'm saying
oh yeah you're never going to convince
at all yeah you're never going to
convince them the goal is not to
convince them the goal is to leave them
yeah I'm the Democratic representative
I represent I I'm the president of the
democratic party if I want to argue with
that guy if that's his title right he
has to quit his job if I win the
argument yes so it's like no I'm not
going to have an argument with him I
just love him where he is and I love
lots of people that are wrong
it's true it's true and by the way the
same thing with that whole like
friendship and like no we can be
friendly and classy and Christian
Brothers whatever you want to leverage
and still disagree yeah and to your
point it's just I'm getting out of this
but I quit having these Christian
discussions I had several of them yeah
in the early days of the radio they'd
call me up brothers in Christ we need to
we need to we need to have Unity we need
to be in agreement on this and I I I'm
just disagreeable right to stupid right
and I you know I've never debated
anybody on any political social
theological issue where I got done with
my points and they went oh again you're
amazingly right I never thought of that
I can't see the world the way you quit
yeah it never happened never happens so
what you've got to do is just go
you're allowed to vote wrong
it's a free country yeah and several of
you do apparently you know and it's
you're you're allowed to sell whole life
you're allowed to you're allowed to and
I still love you I'm still I'm not mad
at you yeah but I mean and there's
probably some stuff I'm wrong but I just
hadn't figured it out yet where do I get
home Sharon will tell me you're
blissfully unaware there we go this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
purpose is my co-host today Corey is in
Dayton Ohio hi Corey welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi thanks for taking my call
guys sure what's up
okay so I'm a 31 year old debt free
intern who only makes about 800 a month
and living with my parents while I
finish my associate's degree I was
wondering if I'm making the right track
with this internship or if I should be
focused on something that makes more
money
well what is the internship what area is
it in and what could it lead to
uh well it's a software development
internship and it leads to a job in
software development
any position but the other people who
have done this path have all been given
the job afterwards for uh software
software development position making
about 72 000 a year okay and how long
are you into the internship and when
will it be over
I'm about six months into the internship
right now and it's going to be over when
I graduate in about a year okay
uh are you doubting that you should stay
with us is that why you called and then
why are you doubting it I'm not
necessarily doubting it I'm well I guess
I am I'm doubting because of how low how
low the money is it's hard to make ends
meet
um making only 800 and I'm wondering if
I should be doing something else
uh well I think the first question I
have is can you supplement that so I
understand why internships don't pay
very well that's just the nature of them
despite a lot of snowflakes thinking
they should get full pay for internships
I love your spirit but that's the nature
of the internship so the question is
between the internship and then your
schooling do you have any time to where
you could be working 20 30 hours a week
to supplement that uh not not a whole
lot of time but I'm sure I can find some
time
um I could probably do Uber or something
are you already writing code
yeah I'm already I'm gifted with code I
know several languages can you not do
some side gigs with code on contract
uh I've never I've never really thought
about that I'm not sure how I would get
into that uh ask anybody sitting around
you at work that's right that's where
they're all doing it
uh but there's another question I have
if let's I'm not asking you to or
telling you to but if you were to pause
this internship today okay and you just
went out into the marketplace based on
the code that you're already able to
write and the experience you have could
you get something that's near the 72 000
uh that would also put you in a position
for growth or do you feel like this is
the best way to get into this work
I think without a little bit more
experience I I it would be very
difficult to
um definitely possible I have a great
resume but with just some more working
experience I think it would be much much
easier what's what's a great resume I
don't understand
um I have good credentials um
uh no I just mean for a job oh in
general like you show up and you bathe
and stuff yeah yeah essentially I got
you okay yeah well I think you have to
weigh what your other options are you
know so for instance it what's the best
way or what's the only way and I don't
think this internship is the only way
but it feels like you believe it's the
best way is that true yes that's true
well then we got to go supplement our
income thankfully mom and dad are
spotting you uh and you've got a Finish
Line that's in sight but I would be
getting after it man and making as much
money as possible so that you're not
struggling why you're getting qualified
I don't think that's the right choice
there's nothing wrong with doing what
you're doing I would do two things what
with along with what Ken's saying I
think he's exactly right number one I
would investigate and get do you do you
have anyone in the coding World outside
of work that knows the world that you
can talk to
Pro professors of mine I could okay
uh number maybe that might give you an
answer I'd like to I'd rather talk to a
practitioner somebody who's actually the
software developer no there we go all
right let's call brother and ask him how
some of the guys do freelance work how
you put yourself out there for contract
on freelance work and would you be
considered maybe a Dev one which is an
entry-level software engineer okay okay
and uh we've got uh I don't know 150 Dev
ones in the building here so I know I
know them well yeah I know your project
every dollar that's I wish I worked on
something like that well maybe maybe
someday we'll get you over here we
always need help but uh anyway the the
thing is if you can
if you can qualify and your current
skill set as a Dev one you're worth more
than 70 grand today
wow okay or if you're not quite
qualified but you can write some basic
entry-level code maybe join a small team
of Freelancers that are doing stuff at
night on the side and you can help them
by providing some of the grunt work and
as just a good side job okay that's a
minimum we need to do that as a minimum
but what I want you to figure out is how
marketable are you already
and if you discover I'm not
no one will hire me as a coder at this
stage I'm not good enough yet then you
stick the intern thing out for sure
okay but if you discover hey I'm already
doing almost Dev one work and I can get
a job making 70 with upside of 110 today
without waiting another year and a half
then you go do that if you've
investigated that it's gonna and either
way you're gonna get peace because if
you discover I'm not ready yet it
answers your question I can be all in on
the internship if you go I am ready
today then there's no sense in making
800 bucks when I could make 80 or 90
grand that's right and so that's the
thing it's about expanding your horizons
uh I'll tell you what Dave I want to
give you my book from paycheck to
purpose and having focus on stage three
which is get connected yeah he's got to
just dive deep there are seven stages
you're already clear you're qualified I
think you need to get connected to see
what's left for you you know if if you
were to contact or be in touch with
people like our senior Dev guys in the
in the in the building they could tell
you in 30 minutes that's right if the
level of code you're writing is
marketable or you are shut up and stay
an intern until you get this crap
figured out right and that's all you
want to know that's all I want to know
if I'm you tell me to shut up and I'll
put my nose down I'll do it that's right
or tell me you're getting you're done
man you can get out there and get moving
let's get out there and get swinging
that's it and I have a formula for
feedback Dave that if anybody this
applies to you I would get three to five
of these conversations that Dave's been
talking about three to five professors
doing it that's right three to five
practitioners okay and that's what we
want to do so we can get a a wide
variety of input and go what are the
averages what are the consistencies
don't just go to one person and get one
person's opinion that's not enough yeah
Dev ones are entering the market it's
above 70. so you're if you're playing
right around there you should be fine
yep and um you know but you may not be
yet and that's okay you're then you need
to stick with the internship and push it
on through but it sounds like that
you've got your path it's just a matter
of whether you need to use this exact
methodology to stay on that path that's
right yeah he knows where he wants to go
now it's just what's the best way to
climb it Anthony is in California hi
Anthony welcome to the Ramsay show
hello hey what's up
hey how's it going Dave thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help
hey so yeah my wife and I we moved um
from Orange County about an hour Inland
it's like an hour and a half with
traffic
and
um we bought a house and uh we're kind
of in a point where we we want to move
back because you know the commute's just
it's kind of killing me I don't really
get to see my family too often
um and then also the uh the area we were
in we had family there or we have family
there but it's just uh
we're realizing why we lived in Orange
County in the first place so
um did you realize that you couldn't
afford it
yeah yeah that's uh that's part of the
reason why we bought you know an hour
Inland yeah because you can't afford to
buy in Orange County
what do you make what's your household
income
um so I mean base is 75 and
um you know usually I kind of make
somewhere between like you know 90 and a
little bit more depending on the year
okay and how old are you
um I just turned 30. okay so if you sell
your house and move back
you're going to be you know you make
good money uh but you don't make good
money for Orange County you just make
enough to survive
uh pretty much yeah I mean we do have
you know family that would be supportive
my family you know we're not we're not
going to set up a life that's not
sustainable that our family has to
support us
yeah you're right that's not a life no
you need to have a plan that's
sustainable where you have dignity you
stand on your own I'm not saying you
can't live in Orange County I'm just
saying that that's the trade-off that's
why you left in the first place
so yeah definitely if you're if you're
done move back but know that you know
home ownership is probably going to be
many years out if ever until you get
your income up and get your career going
and definitely sell the property that
you're leaving behind we're not going to
stay in the rental property business
you're not don't have enough money
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage James
and Becky are with us hey guys how are
you hi hey there welcome welcome where
do you all live we're from Anchorage
Alaska oh little trip to Nashville just
a short John whoa wow well welcome thank
you welcome to the uh sunshine and the
uh and the warmth and the warmth and
stuff yeah not three feet of snow we
really appreciate that well and you yeah
I think we appreciate you leaving it
there so hey good to have you how much
debt have you guys paid off we paid off
222
000
5.34 cents love it how long did that
take almost eight years good for you and
your range of income during that eight
years uh it started out with just me by
myself at about forty thousand dollars a
year and we ended last year at about 230
000. okay she got married along the way
yes and the 222 000 was what kind of
debt it's a little bit of everything so
we had student loans car loans we I had
financed just about everything so it was
it was a little bit everything we were
just just normal yeah okay all right and
so you started this plot process eight
years ago by yourself I did yeah how did
you run into the Ramsey stuff um kind of
on accident so I actually this little
guy that I have with me was six weeks
old and I became a single mom and my
ex-husband got arrested and sentenced to
a long prison term and I got shouldered
with all of our joint debt in the
divorce process and so it was a really
terrifying time and I treaded water for
about four years until a friend at
church said have you ever heard of Dave
Ramsey and I don't think she knew the
monster she was creating but I I went to
FPU I actually went to FPU seven times
and I just kept going back and I kept
going back because I needed to be in
community as a single mom and then at
the the end of that seventh time the
coordinator put his arm around me and
said I think it's time for you to start
teaching this so I've taught I'm
actually about to wrap my seventh class
next week wow so it's it's just it
became a way of life for me so thank you
so that's how we got classes going in
here yes wow you know I I want to follow
up on that because I think people hear
us talk about Financial Peace University
whether they've been here a long time in
the audience or in a short time but as a
single mom going through not just being
a single mom but a traumatic way of
going into that status
it was the community that's why you kept
going back but I want you to go a couple
levels deeper what was it like to go
into those classes all seven of them and
just be a part of something what did it
do for you in your unique situation I
think it just gave me hope and it let me
learn every time I learned something new
it was a little piece of something or I
met somebody or I read something or I
listened to something that just kept
encouraging me and you know you I was
185 000 in debt by myself and I had
forty thousand dollars of income and it
was just kind of like this is not a
possible thing you know this is
insurmountable is what it felt like and
I had this little tiny guy to take care
of all by myself with no child support
so it was just kind of this um it was a
massive fear but it would it was the one
place I could go that I was like these
people get me and they we have these
like-minded
dreams and goals and aspirations and and
they really helped to kind of push me to
just keep going even though it felt like
it was going to take forever how many
times were there where you felt like
quitting and you went to a class and it
changed everything a whole bunch and in
fact there were times when I would take
little hiatuses and I'd have people pop
in and say hey how's it going you know
how have you been where were you at how
are things and you know I started
coordinating when I was still in baby
step two and I was still a single mom
and I just felt like if there was one
person who could get it it was worth it
yeah you know it just made it all worth
it so well you yeah they can't argue
with you I mean you're doing it so there
you go so how long have you all been
married uh just over two years okay how
did you meet we met online and actually
I'll let you tell the first date story
yeah so um my story is uh basically in
my divorce I looked at the assets in
debt and we had nothing in the assets
and everything in the debt and we were
basically splitting debt when we got our
divorce and I just didn't even know what
to do and on our first date uh with this
one she mentioned Dave Ramsey about five
times she was about as subtle as a hand
grenade on that
obviously you were an important part of
her life and I needed to know something
about it so um I was actually in the
middle of selling my house and she was
in the middle of uh her class on on real
estate so she was like hey why don't you
come and take a look at this class and
see what it's like then the next time
she coordinated I was in the front row
first person uh signing up for that
class and uh that had nothing to do with
the clock yeah all right you're so
financially responsible
yeah he fell in love with Dave Ramsey I
don't think so I don't think so I like I
like to say that uh basically she did
all the work like as a single mom
working two three jobs I basically came
in at the end of the marathon with a cup
of water and was like great job
but uh well it did help to get the
income up and be able to attack it and
knock it on and have somebody to be
accountable to right that wasn't well
and encouraging yeah absolutely like
because you
you know you're being Mama Bear out
there fighting on your own scratching
and clawing every day and it just takes
some of the desperation away to have
somebody walking beside you yeah it's a
different thing yeah that's uh it's part
of the emotional journey and uh what you
guys have been through I'm so proud of
y'all thank you well done guys very very
very well done okay now when you're
coaching and you're coordinating these
classes with all these people in there
you did an amazing amazing thing here
and they ask you okay I don't think I
can do it what do you got to do to get
out of debt what do you tell them
um I think my biggest piece that I tell
people is to truly know your worth and
what you're worthy of and what you
actually deserve because there's a lot
of people that are like especially in
Alaska right we hunt we fish we camp we
have Summers that the Sun never goes
down and so we need a camper and we need
the new fishing gear and we need to go
on this hunting Excursion and it's a
boat yeah yeah it's that um you know the
the feeling that you actually deserve
this feeling of not being afraid anymore
you you deserve this you know like not
the handbag not the pedicure not the
trip you know it's and that's what I try
to tell them is it's just it's one step
at a time it's one little bite it's one
little piece
um and you you move forward you know and
eventually it might you might be sucking
wind when you get there but we got there
hey
eight years eight years was it worth it
absolutely absolutely I would do it
again in a heartbeat but you won't have
to no never no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
don't even say that out loud I love it
oh that's a lesson thoroughly learned
yeah oh yeah well done you guys very
very proud of you your Heroes yeah I
gotta ask very quickly
um now you're on the other side of this
and I love how you said you're panting
you know when you finally get there I
mean it's an exhausting Marathon what
are you guys dreaming about now you guys
are a young couple yeah
in January okay
we're growing our family and then we're
looking at doing some traveling and you
know James Works remotely and so he'll
be able to be home a little bit more
instead of us taking those you know 500
mile away jobs and things like that so
let's bring your guy up what is his name
and age his name is Logan and he just
turned 12. all right Logan well done
good stuff oh that's good stuff all
right we've got a copy of the live and
give bundle for you guys it has in it
The Total Money Makeover it has the baby
steps millionaires in it and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
I'm sure you're giving that away yes and
uh you enjoy as much of it as you want
give away the rest of it it's all good
it's here for you to do both so very
proud of you guys thank you very very
well done James Becky and Logan
Anchorage Alaska
222 thousand dollars paid off in eight
years making 45 to 230 the majority of
that she did as a single mom so any of
you out there that think it can't be
done she just might dropped on you there
you go so count it down guys let's hear
a debt free screen
[Music]
[Applause]
that ladies and gentlemen is how it's
done
well
um you just uh have encountered a very
tough
lady with a lot of grit yeah man she
hustled and grind through that that was
amazing how long she pushed and pushed
and pushed until that breakthrough
happens wow powerful powerful this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today David is with us in the San
Antonio hi David welcome to the Ramsay
show
David Ken how are you today better than
we deserve what's up
awesome
um so my wife and I we
want to get into our first house by next
summer when baby step four and five
right now we have a three-year-old and
we have another one on the way in about
two or three weeks so with that being
said our household income is at 157k
going into next year
um so we have been a little last you
know five years or so we've been
contributing money towards our house
fund and to grow stock mutual funds
um so far we have contributed about 166
000 towards that house fund but because
of this
Market that we're in with the stock
market
um it's gone down about 30k so right now
we're about 135 000 in that house fund
my question
is
do we take that hit of that 30k to get
into a house in the next six to eight
months or do we just write it out you
know until we at least get I would say
at least half that back in that in that
fund yeah
when are you thinking about buying a
home
uh well our lease is up in May at the
end of May this year and 23 yes this
year yes sir yep sure you got six months
yep so we're looking at about you know
June July probably and we can always do
like the month-to-month police too if we
need to
all right I I cannot figure out exactly
what you've got your money in because
it's down more than the market is down
yeah so our portfolio's down about I
live today about 21
um and we have in the last 12 months
about Jones is off seven percent
yeah and again I've been self I've been
self-managing this
um so like I said I mean just doing the
the regular four that you that you you
know teach but again I'm not I'm not
gonna make that bad on on your teachings
I don't know no no they're not putting
Mutual putting across those four mutual
funds
uh for the short term is never a play
um you had a five-year window and the
five-year Windows very seldom lose money
if you'd have just been in a simple
growth stock mutual fund that followed
the market like an S P 500 as an example
right that's probably what I would have
put you in for saving for a house
instead of across those four the four
are for primarily for long-term plays
and
um retirement accounts and so forth
anyway that's neither here nor there
this is where we are so the the question
is this it is not what you started with
that causes you to make the decision
to pull it
it's what you think it's going to do
right so I mean let's pretend you
started with um
a hundred thousand and it was worth 160.
then you know you still have to make the
decision do I pull it now
based on what I think it's going to do
between now and may of 23 if it's going
down and then back up and then back down
and it's net down of what I put in which
is where you are I have to make the
decision what do I think it's going to
do between now and may of 23. so the the
past causes us to be emotional but it's
really not your best you know you don't
you don't say well I'm trying to recover
some of the money that's called a cost
analysis and that's always a fallacy you
don't want to use that as your critical
thinking path your critical thinking
path is
I I I I reach unnecessary ending with
anything an investment a relationship a
job whatever it is when I lost when I've
lost hope for the future
and you don't have to completely lose
hope in the stock market but your hope
would if you've lost hope that in the
next
uh six months from now until May of 23
that the market is going to go up is it
going to go up over the next six months
if you think no then you would get out
today
if you think yes then you would stay in
I truly don't know what it's going to do
between now and may I have no idea what
would I do if I were in your shoes
huh
I would
um I'm pretty risk-averse I don't like
Risk
um I the things I buy and invest in are
very conservative generally speaking so
I'm couching my answer in that
I'm probably going to split the
difference I'm probably going to pull
half of it
and let the let the less rest of it ride
until May and let's see if I can make
some back on that but that way I've
limited the the whole stinking thing's
not going to go down another 30 grand on
me right yeah no way and yeah and so
but I have no idea I mean we've got so
many things affecting this economy now
in the short term that are negative
uh interest rates we they're you know
the FED is doing its best to push us
into a recession to slow interest rate
growth
um they've stated that
um and so what does that do the stock
market not necessarily anything except
if profits go down because consumer
activities go down like buying crap then
uh you're going to see the market drop
more so I don't know uh because we're
being so poorly LED right now on the
economic front that the the variables
that government does control are
screwing up everything
um right I'm being pretty negative so
what would I I would build half of it
I'd blow half of it and I'd ride with
the other half interesting all right
yeah
over the last couple months or so we've
been we've decided to like not put the
money into the mutual funds start
savings I would add no more yeah I would
add no more right exactly and so this
kind of clears things I have some we've
been fighting with the last couple
months now let me let me say really
really loudly because people are I
always get misquoted and misconstrued
and misconstrued and everything
um but so really really really loudly I
am not saying that you should pull your
money out of mutual funds if you're in a
long-term investment situation you're
not a long-term investment situation
you're in a short term
but 100
of my 401K money is in mutual funds the
four types you're talking about and 100
of it is staying there
I'm not moving a dime out of the market
for the long term I have not lost hope
in the market in the long term I just
don't know what the flip is going to
happen with these idiots in Washington
between now and May
they could screw up Christmas they've
still got two weeks to do it but um yeah
I mean it's just you know what I'm
saying it's just I do I'm somewhat
optimistic and with the caveat that
nobody can predict what the Market's
going to do however I'm always half full
I think you're going to see a lot of
companies already doing it you're seeing
a lot of major public companies do
layoffs to get control of their balance
sheet we went on a rant about this last
week to make more profits to make more
profit so I do think you're going to see
the stock market uh I think it's going
to be pretty good first and second
quarter I think things are going to
stabilize there because I do think the
inflation situation and even though the
fed's going to keep bumping the rates
the job markets are very strong I don't
see that being affected so I think it's
going to shake out yeah the real estate
market has slowed down but it needed to
it had to it was overheated that's right
it's not it's not it's not diving or
anything like that it's doing about what
we told you it was going to do it's
going to go up five to seven percent in
23. and would you say the fundamentals
are ripe for a nice rebound because
inventory is still low oh I don't think
there's gonna be a rebound because
everybody's got their lips stuck out and
is whining about interest rates and a
lot of people think
psychologically that the market is
actually worse than it really is right
so um you know no I've got a property on
the market that I'm liquidating and they
came in with less than a full price
offer the other day and I told them I'll
wait how long before you think uh the
American house Shopper psyche adjusts to
this new interest rate reality well I
mean let's face it we're all drama
queens
so we overplay the up and we overplay
the down
you know it's like
really as awesome as you're acting like
oh God
oh God not as much as you say I mean
they overplay it right and so it's and
part of that is they watch the news too
much and believe what's on the news
correct and uh you know if you're
getting your information from people in
the Bathtubs at the break or walk-in
bathtubs you know you've got crazy
information all right so um it's just
like I call that headline hysteria yeah
exactly and I think that affects it more
than it really is so the market has
slowed down we told you it was going to
slow down we needed to slow down the
real estate market so I don't know what
stock market's gonna do between now and
then I really don't but long term I'm
100
have not changed an
ounce of that do not tell people I said
to pull your money on the market because
it's going down I did not say that I was
talking about May
God
people show overly clear this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here diesel Ramsey
show is one of the most popular podcasts
in the world it's your daily dose of
advice on life and money check out all
of our shows from the Ramsay Network
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is done cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money thank you for
joining us
Merry Christmas
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Amy is with
us in Salt Lake City hi Amy how are you
I'm well how are you better than I
deserve what's up
good so we are on baby step three and
our family car has about 185 000 miles
on it and starting to give us trouble
and was planning on driving it till we
can anymore but my question is do we
pause our baby step three and start
saving money for a newer replacement
no baby step 3 is your emergency fund
and your replacement is not yet an
emergency you're saying it may become
one
but right now it's not
and so you know since it's not an
emergency
um no uh I'm gonna drive it and
hopefully you can finish baby step three
and then save up enough to buy the next
car before it gives out on you if it
does give out on you before that then
some portion of the next purchase
becomes an emergency but you're going to
have to limit severely the car you
purchased to replace it
okay and if it does like stop working
before we finish baby step three what's
a good uh price for a car to pay while
we're still in baby step three if that
happens well the minimum possible
because transportation is the emergency
upgraded transportation is not the
emergency
okay so basically you know basic
Transportation I'm looking just for some
old beater that I can drive around
here's the thing you probably can patch
the car that you've got and make it
through this even if it lays down a
little bit I don't think it's going to
suddenly just completely the wheels fall
off the thing
it'll probably be a nickel and Diamond
drive you crazy for a little while and
I'd rather you do that then and buy the
proper car that's going to be a car you
keep for a little while
then uh you know buy a two thousand
dollar car and then later on have to buy
an 8 000 car
what's your household income
um 130 okay you're gonna get there so
fast it doesn't matter yeah yeah that's
the point and so yeah get there as fast
as you can that reminds me I think this
is a good insight for folks I remember
years ago uh Stacy and I were paying off
debt we were living in Atlanta and we
had the three little ones and we had an
older Suburban it was great thing ran
forever and the transition was starting
to go on it so we went took it in and it
was going to be about five grand to
replace the transmission well to me I'm
sitting there look at that going oh
until you do the research and you go
I've got the money and the five grand to
fix that thing the mechanic was like
it's gonna keep running for a long time
if you spend the five grand versus 15 or
20 or whatever else you do and so in
that situation it was a no-brainer to
replace the transmission and we got five
more years out of that car yeah and it
was still running when we sold it yeah
oh yeah here's the thing you there's uh
I would estimate and I'm making this up
but I'm not far off that less than five
percent of the time
do repairs make selling the car a better
situation you're almost always
mathematically better off to fix it yeah
and keep driving it I agree with that
fix it and keep driving the thing that
happens though is twofold
um one is you start to have just this
down time in the hassle Factor yeah
starts to be just a complete pain in the
butt but mathematically not emotionally
not I'm worried about my wife ending up
on the side of the road at 10 o'clock at
night okay that not not that kind of
thing but just the math of the repairs
versus what I would spend to replace the
car it almost never makes sense to
upgrade in car but it does make sense
not mathematical sense to move up in car
because you get rid of hassle Factor you
increase convenience and reliability and
things that are not math but that are
quality of life yeah and so yeah you do
move up in car later oh yeah and I'm
telling you I was reading something the
other day depends on the make and model
and I'm not going to get into this now
but I mean it is very normal now for a
car to go into the 250 300 000 miles I
mean I see old like uh Land Cruisers
which I'm into that kind of older stuff
yeah these cars have 250 300 000 miles
on and they keep running forever if you
take care of them oh there's a lot of
models that'll get three four hundred
thousand if they're taken care of yeah
it's but again it just reaches the point
that the technology parts replacement
finding somebody to work on them and
they will you know they're gonna leave
you and you got to get them fixed you
know and then you gotta you got to deal
with it and uh but new car I'll leave
you on the side of the road I got a
friend driving a dead gun Bentley left
him on the side of the road the other
day so uh oh that's all you know it was
a flat tire but um okay but uh but just
the same I mean uh you know you could
still there's no guarantee you're not
going to be stuck does a person with
light gloves come out and change the
tires for you I have no idea okay I
suspect a helicopter came in with a hook
picked it up and him up and fed him
caviar on the way back to the dealership
I don't know but yeah but I mean the
point is that all these all the stupid
cars they all break down that's true
that's right just a thing so you just
you're not going to get it completely
away from that hey folks if you're a
small business owner uh and you've got
small business questions we're going to
be doing an entree leadership theme hour
very soon we want to hear from you about
your current pain whatever it is you're
dealing with managing your team managing
your budget uh marketing questions small
business questions of any kind maybe
family business questions uh anything
you want to talk about for entree
leadership for business and small
business questions we need to set you up
to be part of this upcoming entree
leadership theme hour text your
questions or email your questions rather
to ask
at ramseysolutions.com put entree theme
hour in the subject line ask at
ramsaysolutions.com if you've gone
through Financial Peace University
chances are it's because someone in your
life lit a fire under your little butt
mom and dad gave it to you as a gift
your pastor offered it to you at your
church the one friend that wouldn't stop
talking about it someone got you moving
so you finally took the class you
finally started working the baby steps
and now changed everything
you're out of debt well maybe now you
can light a fire under somebody this
Christmas give someone you care about
Financial Peace University
you can share the same hope
that you've discovered with money the
same freedom
that you've discovered with money the
same power
that you've discovered with money
and they'll also get the premium version
of every dollar and group coaching with
our team of financial coaches so this
Christmas give the people you care about
a gift that actually matters hope
freedom
power
to give Financial Peace universities a
gift to go to ramseysolutions.com
give FPU
ramseysolutions.com give
FPU and there's no shipping involved so
it'll be like instantaneous well we'll
send you a gift card so they'll know
they got it and all that but if you do
it right now we can still get it to you
for Christmas hey that's pretty cool
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Tommy's in Cincinnati hey Tommy welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey thank you guys for having me
gentleman how are you doing today better
than we deserve sir how can we help okay
so I I'm just kind of first and foremost
I'm grateful to be on the call my wife
and I uh newly debt free I thank you
guys for your leadership there on in
your guidance
um I mean between the two of us we make
roughly 138 thousand dollars per year I
have been in a job I'm 35 years old for
about 15 years with the federal
government I'm working for a government
agency
um and at 30 years
um so at the time I'm 50 I'll be
eligible for a monthly annuity or
pension
um kind of growing up I've heard of my
grandparents having pensions so on and
so forth uh they obviously uh are doing
well but aside from them I haven't
really encountered anyone with attention
so I have this kind of perfect ideal
picture of what it's like to have a
pension
um and especially at the age of 50 you
know just kind of enticing well as a
you're you're not here how old now again
I'm 35 years old so okay so 15 more
years okay yep yep
um well today I was just offered uh
another job uh working in the private
sector uh making about forty to fifty
thousand dollars more depending on the
bonus but uh an annual bar or excuse me
an annual base salary of about forty
thousand dollars more per year
um and uh just kind of curious you know
which way would you lean on on going
um that would bring our household income
to roughly eighty thousand dollars per
year
I thought you were getting a potential
raise he did 50 000. okay so that last
one Thirty to 180 right
oh you said oh look I thought you said
80 for a second well so let's move let's
remove the money from the conversation
when you heard about this job
opportunity okay I understand the bump
uh and it's in the private sector but do
you get excited about the actual work
itself and then where it might lead
yes I guess yes yes and no
um yes and just in terms of doing
something different right I've been
doing my current job for 15 years
um on the younger side of things sure um
but really don't know a whole lot else
all right let me ask you this do you
what's your enjoyment level of your
government job right now on a scale of
one to ten one being suck and ten being
you love it
um I would say eight I I I I I like it
pretty well so here's the deal number
one I wouldn't stay in any job for any
pension just for the pension the pension
to me would never be the reason I would
stay all right and the good news is you
you got an eight uh that's a pretty high
level of enjoyment most Americans aren't
experiencing an eight in their work so
that's good on the other hand uh you
know going to the private sector with an
opportunity to move up the ladder and
make more money uh I would do that in
regards to just staying for a pension so
you're kind of in this uh middle area
for me there's not a clear winner
because you could take this job the
private sector job make more money uh
even have an opportunity for advancement
but if you don't enjoy the work and it's
just oh I'm doing it because it's
something different let me tell you
something you got about 40 percent of
people who change jobs in the last two
years regret changing their jobs because
the paycheck or off the promotion wore
off and they realized they were better
off where they were and that concerns me
your answer of it's just something
different well once the different weight
wears off now you could be stuck so what
do you do now
um like what agency what's your day job
what's your title what do you do
yeah so I am like a customer service
person uh working for a a state agency
or excuse me a federal agency that helps
with grants so you're in customer
service okay and so you would be doing
what at the new place
um I would be working for a
telecommunications company working with
local municipalities and managing their
contracts
so kind of in the same field
correct yep absolutely
so theoretically you could get a you
could have an eight in on the enjoyment
meter at this at this new job as well
correct
um yeah yeah I think you need to dig in
a little bit more you know because
because it's a no-brainer for me if you
were to tell me that you could enjoy the
private sector job and to provide you a
ladder for Financial and Professional
growth it's a no-brainer to me to take
the Privacy if you've got if you've got
as good an environment or better you've
got as good a pro a chance of
progressing or better and your level of
enjoyment is as good or better 100 take
the new job yeah
okay because a pension versus 50 Grand
is an easy decision yes that you know
let's just say 15 years you're talking
about sitting there waiting on this
pension 15 years of 50 Grand is called
750 Grand
that that'll build you a pension my man
for sure for sure self-induced cell
phone self-run self everything and
you'll you know show them you're going
to make a lot more money in the private
sector than your pension would ever even
come close to
um and uh the the you know well it's
secure not listen there's nothing it's
there's nothing secure don't your
position is only as secure As You Are
your ability to go get something is your
security and so and you've already
proven that so yeah as long as the
company is solid there's not a bunch of
toxic environment and you're not just
going just for the money the people that
have had the regret went just for the
money and they ignored the other
variables and they stepped in it yep
that's exactly right so they get there
and they realize wait a second uh I was
really excited about the paycheck bump
and maybe a nice new title but uh I
don't enjoy coming into work yeah these
people their their values are screwed up
yeah they may treat you like you're just
a commodity instead of a human being
hello you were able to be purchased
that's a very good point that's a very
good point you you they dangled the
carrot and you went after you if you act
like a commodity then guess what they
might treat you like a commodity and you
might sign up for being a commodity yeah
and then you get dumped on the street
the first time they decide they're going
to raise profits by decreasing payroll
that's called layoffs in Corporate
America for no reason other than
increase fishing profits
and they do it every day I've been
announcing them left and right like
crazy so that's the thing you don't want
to get into if you've got but if you've
got a solid company they're going to
treat you well you feel like your
enjoyment is there your your chances are
progressing in the field are just as
good or better
um you know you're never trade a pension
or benefits for that always take the
upside always yeah the per the uh
purported Security will always let you
down well I mean we have an investment
strategy that you've been teaching for
decades and it works and that's what
we're talking about here the pay raise
plus you using that strategy you're
gonna get further faster than the
pension ever would get you yeah I mean
50 Grand 750 in 15 years that'll that
adds up for you before you're eligible
for the pension you made an extra three
quarters of a million dollars yeah that
and that's not counting any raises you
would have gotten over and Beyond what
the federal government is going to give
you so take the job if all things are
equal that's the answer to the equation
yeah
so many people don't take the job
without making sure all things are equal
that's the issue like you gotta dig and
it's as simple as like talking to people
who work there talking to somebody who
knows somebody that works over there now
again you don't take one squeaky wheel
and say oh well this is a horrible
company you gotta get real feedback get
real mature people who are going to tell
you what it's like there and that is not
hard to find out but you got to be
intentional yeah I mean you can find
people that don't like anything that's
right we'll guarantee you I mean we we
have an incredible culture in Ramsay and
Ramsay Solutions is a world-class place
to work but you can find people that are
pissed off I've read nonsensical
straight up lies about our organization
as if I wasn't in the building I've read
this crap on social media and all that
people do this people squeaky wheels
will do that in any company not just
Ramsay any company and it's like you got
to talk to enough people to know whether
or not we got somebody who's angry or
somebody who's hurt or straight up crazy
so because I've seen it all
yeah and you can find somebody
displeased with anything and some of
them have an agenda X Grand so that's
anyway the uh us included that's right
and in at that place so don't just take
one that's right do your homework make
sure you're uh that you're not just
trading your soul for money
that's what you don't want to do but if
you can uh keep your soul and have a
great work environment and make more
money Yes Trade 50 grand for a pension
in about a nanosecond this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today
our research team did the largest study
of millionaires ever done in North
America over ten thousand one hundred
and sixty seven of them and we
discovered the top five careers of
people who become millionaires
turns out it's controversial who knew
ever thought it would be controversial
but it's actually a fact sometimes facts
are controversial who knew that yeah
this is a fact the number one career and
the largest study of millionaire has
ever done was engineers
number two was accountant
number three was teacher
number four was Management number five
was attorney
doctors didn't make the top five they
came in at number six
MD's doctors
interesting
and when I post this on the internet
um it's like the whole world came to an
end because we suggested teachers can
win well teachers can win and they do it
all the time and the actual study proved
that now uh well teachers don't get paid
enough I wasn't making a comment on that
one way or the other I just said that
the largest study of millionaire has
ever done concluded that the number
three
most likely career to become a
millionaire as a teacher you might
disagree with that but you would be
what's known as wrong
because it's a fact
facts aren't controversial see this is
the reason I wrote Baby Steps
millionaires Ken is because these people
are out there who are just bound and
determined to lose
they want an excuse to lose they want an
excuse to be a victim and I'm not going
to give you an excuse I'm going to tell
you you can win and I'm going to show
you the facts on how to help becoming a
baby steps millionaire is real and now
it's available at only ten dollars my
latest number one New York Times bus not
New York Times my latest number one
best-selling book baby steps
millionaires I I'm not on the New York
Times because I said they sucked on the
air so I'm not not on there anymore but
but anyway so yeah but I'm it was number
one in the nation and yeah ten dollars
at ramsaysolutions.com before the deal
is gone don't miss this Cindy's with us
Cindy is in Louisville Kentucky hi Cindy
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave it's a pleasure to meet you
um your program really made a huge
difference for my family and it's it's
just been a big deal for for generations
of my family so thank you for that well
thank you how can we help
so my husband and I have been saving up
for a couple years he's been saving up
since before we got married and so have
I
um and we've got about a hundred
thousand dollars saved up I have
deferred some of my retirement savings
but he's doing the 15 he's supposed to
do because we want to buy our first
house
um we're currently running from a family
member and I've done a lot of the
repairs on that so I'm fairly handy
there's a house that we're looking at
that is an old Victorian house you can
probably see where this is about to go
it's a bank owned property they're
asking about 250 000 for it and I think
it would be worth easily that if it were
fully repaired I think it'd be worth a
lot more
the problem is that it needs some
significant repairs and when I say
significant I mean probably needs to be
completely rewired
it still has old black metal pipes that
are going to have to get torn out
and obviously some of those go through
the walls which are old plaster walls
that could be a lot of work getting that
out and the HVAC systems
have some obvious issues with the way
they've been wired in and installed
so my question really is
how much we should be willing to offer
it also my husband and I are expecting a
baby in February so I'm pretty handy
there are a lot of things I can do there
are a lot of things I can't do pregnant
or postpartum
um the bank have a pretty pretty adamant
that they did not want to take less than
the 250 they were asking I think they're
getting that number personally based off
of uh property taxes were just
reassessed on it and shitty says that's
what the property taxes are
but
um they weren't really willing to come
down on the property please please
please please
walk away
nothing in you said in this entire
conversation sounds fun
that listen I've done historic rehabs
they don't build them like they used to
thank God
we have learned a lot about construction
techniques since 1916 and that's why we
don't put knob and tube wiring in things
and while we don't put those black pipes
in there and why we don't use plaster
anymore and why we don't and why we
don't and why we don't and why we don't
this is your very first house and your
very first rehab in your very first
series of things and you keep telling me
how handy you are you ain't that handy
yeah this is a disaster you ever seen
the movie Money Pit
you know I can't say I have well you
ought to go watch it it'll tell you not
to do this deal yes okay
please don't do this deal here's the
thing this sounds cute and you're
looking for a deal and you're willing to
do some repairs and you're signing up
for 10 to 15 x what you think you're
signing up for in hassle in unknowns
it's almost impossible to run an
accurate estimate on the rehab because
every time you open up a wall there's
another dadgum mess in that wall
yeah and you can't have to do a plaster
you get one shot the whole wall or
nothing
you can't patch plaster
you can patch drywall
you can't patch plaster
you can tell it it's you know there's a
there's no technique that does this so
you take the whole wall off and then you
get to do the whole wall back and oh God
it's you know if you want to do that you
need to be an experienced rehabber that
knows something about historic
Renovations this is a massive project
let me just tell you if you want to
build a home from the ground up it would
be 10x easier than the project you're
talking about and I've done lots of both
lots of both I actually know what I'm
talking about
yeah I definitely appreciate that yeah
do not do this deal
the bank is too high they're out of
their dadgum mines you're pregnant and
the last thing you need is another child
that's a that's a problem child house
yeah Cindy I think you need a new vision
I think you've had a great vision for
this you guys have looked at this how
your vision got your vision got uh uh
kidnapped yeah you know this happened by
this one stupid house because it's it's
so cute and ginger pretty and looks like
it could be so cool on the Outside
Inside is Hell on Earth yeah it's a
great vision but not a great decision
you know that's the issue you can do
this somewhere else hold walk away on
this deal and find another thing that's
a much better deal where you can let
that Vision kind of go but that's that's
what they're wrestling with yeah you're
gonna have to strip every wall and come
back with every single piece of Plumbing
every Plumbing fixture every piece of
wiring every plug the the the main the
electrical main the water main all have
to be replaced everything in there or
you're never gonna get it right you
can't patch this because the the system
is bad and it's ancient yeah
I think that we when we were talking
about it originally we're like if we
were gonna do it if we were going to be
able to pull this off the only way we
could do it is really to take it you
know first floor and get the first floor
functional and then over the course of a
couple years get that second job I can't
stop you can I
problem yeah that's a problem you're
getting ready to pay too much and you're
underestimating your costs and you're
underestimating the emotional pain it's
going to take to finish this project
dramatically
dramatically Cindy not just a little bit
Cindy dramatically yeah I don't hate
historics I hate historics as your first
rehab I hate historics being done by a
woman who just had her first baby I hate
historics for the first home you ever
own in your life oh it's like buying a
car out behind some Old Farmer's house
that's rusted and you're going to take
it all the way down to the frame and
you're going to build it back with your
bare freaking hands and end up with a
car when you're done that's not as good
as a new car
cars are the same way I love old cars
but they don't build them like they used
to thank God we got these new things
called disc brakes they're amazing you
know oh geez this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day Psalm 32 and 8
I will instruct you and teach you in the
way you should go I will counsel you
with my eye upon you
Tony Dungy said I am a firm believer
that the Lord sometimes has to
short-circuit even our best plans for
our benefit
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money
oh Kevin is with us in Tampa hi Kevin
how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up oh this is my first
time talking to you Dave so I'm really
nervous but excited so thank you for the
um for answering my call well we're
honored how can we help
I've been a long time listener basically
so um I paid off my debt um saved up
um my three to six months of expenses
for emergencies way to go into investing
way to go
so now I'm basically new to investing
and I'm also new to the comp the company
that I work for
um they match up to six percent but they
don't start matching until I reach one
year so I was wondering so because you I
already know you always talk about you
know matching Beach Roth Beach
traditional should I wait for the year
and just invest in my Roth IRA and then
once I hit that one year of service
um start in um matching up to six
percent and then the nine percent to
Roth
is your 401K Roth available
without the match
um
or you can't be in it at all it is but I
have a Roth account with Vanguard but I
mean you can't be in the company 401 at
all for a year is that what you're
saying
I mean I can but they don't match they
don't start matching it okay can it be
wrong
um I didn't look into it that far okay
because some some 401ks are Roth and
some don't offer that so it's up to your
company to offer a Roth 401k if you can
do a Roth 401k with no match for the
first year and after that it's a match I
would do that and the reason is is that
way you don't end up with this one Loan
account sitting out over here as a Lone
Ranger just stuck off to the side I'm
just trying to keep your life simple
there's it's not wrong to invest in the
other it's just one more file you've got
to keep in your file drawer right
right so I'm just trying to keep it
simple so if you've got Roth 401k with
good options without a match for year
one and after that with a match that
that would be my first choice if they
only have traditional with a match after
a year yeah go ahead and do your Roth
because you're going to want to do that
anyway because you only want to take up
to the match after they give the match
you're going to need the Roth anyway
awesome thank you so much you see how
I'm doing that does that make sense
hey thanks for the call brother Merry
Christmas to you open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Sue is with us in Austin Texas hi Sue
how are you
oh great how are you better than I
deserve what's up
but I also am I weighing that against
self-insuring
so I don't know which is more advisable
okay I don't do short-term care policies
long-term care is nursing home insurance
most of those policies today last about
three years is that what you're seeing
yes sir how old are you
55. okay I would not buy it until you're
60. the statistical probability of being
in a nursing home before 60 is close to
zero
okay but after 60 it goes up every day
so if you're gonna buy we would buy
after 60 and I would buy long-term care
and it would cover usually about three
years worth of care which by the way uh
almost every nursing home state does not
exceed three years
once you go in you that's usually that's
about it okay so statistically now
that's not some people make it 10 years
in a nursing home other people make it
10 days
but the average is the average is is 2.7
years
okay I got it so uh you do the hype I'm
sorry go ahead you're fine
what I would you do the hybrid the
long-term care hybrid or just the
traditional long-term care insurance
hybrid meaning what
the one that has the life insurance no I
would not do that benefit no that is not
that's horrible no stay away from those
completely no you don't need life
insurance you need long-term care or you
don't now you said self-insure so the
average you're in Texas your average
nursing home care there's going to be
about 85 000 a year
and if the average stay is 2.7 years
your average exposure and if your
average coverage is three years worth of
policy which is about what they'll cover
you is let's call it 300 Grand okay so
that's what you could burn through on
average now you could burn through four
or 500 Grand you could burn through 100
Grand but somewhere in that range is the
where we're playing how what's your net
worth
um uh
let's see I don't really know I mean I
think about
six hundred thousand maybe seven hundred
okay I don't know how to calculate it
okay well it's what you own minus what
you owe
okay so you have any debt
a house one hundred twenty three
thousand but I have ninety thousand in
the bank
and then about six hundred thousand in
Ira or what's the house works
380.
you would say pay off the house yeah but
okay let's call that yeah and so so you
got a 400 000 house and six hundred
thousand dollars in in your retirement
accounts give or take okay if you paid
the house off that's where we'd be
roughly so you got about a million
dollars way to go good job Sue oh here's
the neat thing in every seven years if
that's invested and it's making is it
invested in mutual funds
uh yes okay if it's invested in mutual
funds every seven years it'll double
okay if it's averaging ten percent or
better it'll double in seven years so in
seven years when you're 62 you're gonna
have 1.2 million
it sounds like the way we're having this
discussion that you're single are you
single
no
oh okay
my husband
okay
and already retired obviously does he
have long-term care insurance
no okay we don't have kids either okay
so if he went into a nursing home
because he's older than you
and he burns through three or four
hundred grand are you okay
I think you need long-term care
insurance on him
he doesn't talk
okay all right he has one of those
that's your big risk you're not the big
risk he is
[Applause]
and then but you got 600 000 bucks to
work with and you got a house that's
almost paid for could be paid for if you
decide to pay for it today so you've
done a great job I'm not going to fret
and wring my hands over this but you
need to be thinking about how you're
going to care for him you could do
in-home care it's actually a high
quality of care where you bring in a
nurse in a hospital bed and just take
care of him in the home with some help
and um that actually ends up being a
high quality situation and if it's done
right and uh and can be uh cheaper in
some cases yeah so if I'm hearing this
Dave so right now we want to take care
of he's not qualified so we wait five
years for her to get her own laundry and
by then she's going to be self-insured
for hers right yeah and he's not going
to be left with her right needs being
need to be covered it's going to be the
other way around so 75 percent of you
ladies outlive your husbands
that's the statistics
and the normal statistic that happens is
let's say Papa and Mama got six they got
300 000 bucks saved up or 400 000 bucks
saved up and papa goes into the nursing
home and he burns through 300 and leaves
Mama broke
after they worked their whole lives and
they did have a pretty decent Nest Egg
so that's that's the situation where you
desperately need to get long-term care
insurance when you turn 60 years old you
need to go get long-term care to take
care of to protect the nest egg for Mama
because statistically usually it's mama
left behind and then she's got the three
or four hundred grand because you had
insurance to cover his three or four
hundred grand worth of a nursing home
need if you've got 10 million dollars or
you've got three million dollars well
self-insure through it mama's gonna be
okay right that's right that's the plan
can call me good show today well done
Austin Finn James Zack and will in the
booth the booth dudes did a great job as
always I am Dave Ramsey your host we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign